speech-to-text api can be used to  convert audio to text in 120 languages  let's see how to use speech API with  c-sharp first make sure the API is  enabled in your project and a service  that can exist to make API calls both  are explained in the code web in the  video note in cloud shell let's create a  simple dotnet console app and add speech  API nougat package to the project open  the code editor and navigate to program  dot C s we will transcribe an audio file  save on Google Cloud storage first  reference to the speech API library  create a speech client specify speech  API configuration  point to the audio on Google Cloud  Storage call recognized method and  finally print the results let's run the  app there you go you just use the  speech-to-text  API to convert audio to text